i wrote a book a couple of years ago and
there's a whole chapter dedicated to
your woman cave
yes your woman cave i love that
yeah but you know the good thing is is
that if you don't live with anyone you
can make the whole damn house your woman
cave
that's what i'm doing
i i actually
so i've
had quite a crazy life a lot of trauma a
lot of stuff that led to me getting into
kind of some crazy stuff sexually and i
had a dungeon up into my in my house
like built a bed like this whole crazy
thing yeah and i finally like it's been
a room that i really don't go in
and i yesterday so i'm stoked to like be
talking with you i'm on a whole high
right now because yesterday we found an
artist because i
where i have people redoing my closets
and all this stuff and we were talking
about the getting this thing out of my
house i have this monstrosity custom
made bed that i
designed without knowing my trauma like
literally didn't have the memories and
all of the stuff that i got into on
in my life and i'm you know i'm not here
to judge but i everything that i was
into sexually related back to stuff that
i ultimately remembered
in my trauma memories
and i talked really candidly candidly
about this because it's like i'm just
don't i just this topic needs to be
spoken about and it needs to be
a conversation we can have it at a
dinner table and then move on and have
dessert and be fine you know i love that
i love that keep going i think this is
you know for those those brave and
vulnerable and transparent enough
to and strong enough to
say it should yeah it's not everyone's
place not everyone has the ability to
say it but if you do
and then the people that you help are
are ones that would never otherwise get
it you know a hundred percent but also
if one of us is speaking it's all of us
i am the voice of anyone who doesn't
feel like they want to speak i'm your
voice i'm i'm
your voice and you can feel through me
that we are speaking up together because
we're the same i mean it it's that's
that's how i see it anyway but but this
this whole this freaking dungeon bed is
like was just absorbing energy in my
house and you can see like i want a zen
den so i'm literally turning it into a
meditation room but my organizer was so
amazing i kept feeling like just really
not cool about i just wanted to get rid
of it i didn't want someone to buy it
because i didn't want it to be used for
this purpose anymore and she said
there's an artist who wants to repurpose
it and i literally dance i literally
burst into tears i was just like i was
so overwhelmed with relief but also it
was like the universe just saying no we
hear you
we're not gonna let this be something
that could possibly become more of a you
know harmful thing in any way shape or
form yeah a tool in that regard um
and and
it's going to be repurposed it's going
to be used in an artistic exhibit and
i'm just like so happy it's gonna be out
of my house i already have the design
for the meditation room so it'll be a
this is obviously my meditation living
room there's my meditation bedroom
that'll be my meditation meditation room
you know every as you said in my whole
house it'll be that but but that will be
a dedicated room that the energy will
will go from what it has been to just
being the space that i know i want to
hang out in all the time so i'm really
excited
to go there again and use the room for a
different purpose and having to go
through that that alchemical process of
turning it from one thing into another
and you've talked about that for
yourself and i just think that you know
you said that to change the narrative
around trauma that you have to say like
how did how did we get here how did i
get here
so
maybe this is the perfect time to just
start off by like how did you get here
my life is kind of lipped out in
segments there there was the
um
0 to 15 years old segment where i live
with my family parents home schooled
went from k through 12 in home school so
never actually went to a
typical school
um graduated when i was 15 two months
later i moved
or two months after i turned 15 i
graduated and moved out of the house
became fully independent and then you
have like my 15 to 18 year period where
i'm studying acting and i'm in new york
and i'm determined that i'm going to be
an actress and everybody told me it was
never going to happen because you know
trailer park kids don't make it in
hollywood and i was like um has anyone
ever heard of hilary swank
i think so um
but i was a little bit of a was as a
strong word i was a little bit of an
arrogant child
i was like y'all are all wrong i'm gonna
prove it and um so then there was that
period of just like just just
really treading through the muck of it
all to make stuff happen in kind of a
forcing kind of way
um toxic hustling i think is what they
call it now
good one
right um i heard that term recently and
i was like yeah we god we're sold this
american lie not an american dream it's
it's like you you
but literally you go into your life
being told that if you go after your
dreams meaning if you do a career that
we approve of will mean that you are
quote unquote successful
you're going to be happy and we'll be
happy
with society or we meaning your family
i think all of the above right i mean it
depends this is obviously it's
definitely society and culture a lot of
people's families there are the few who
are like be whatever you want free
little bird
i love those people i haven't met them
but i i figure they're out there
but we as society we as a culture we as
parents teachers community peer you know
all of the above
literally drink the kool-aid and then
pour that kool-aid into a little tiny
sippy cup for a child to drink and
from the time we're you know we can
start to talk we're we're being asked
what do we want to do when we grow up
and then we're asked what do we do when
we're at an event and it's just so i
wanted to make sure that what i did was
something that i was proud of and
um and that i thought would make me
important and make me more importantly
be seen because i felt invisible i felt
unseen and invisible in the world
because when you're a traumatized kid
you feel like nobody sees you you feel
like you don't exist